Nick Jonas opens up about his  relationship with lily collins ET caught  up with the jealous singer at the ESPN  the party event on Friday where he  narrowly avoids addressing whether he is  dating the 26 year old actress who also  happens to be musician Phil Collins  daughter I hate to say it but your love  life is always in their headlines can  you comment on the lily rumors I can't  at all you can't at all at all thanks  Nate  although Nick adorably pled the fifth  about his reported new romance with Lily  a source tells et things are really  heating up between the two adding quote  they have been hanging out  they are both into each other during the  couples latest adventure a weekend at  Mammoth Mountain ski resort Lily shared  this snap on Instagram of the getaway  writing hashtag a filling like the top  of the world